let's go into number two
this is going to infuriate some people
but there's going to be a few points in
here i'll be honest with you that are
going to
infuriate some people but you guys will
live you'll be just fine
flirt with other women number two make
her jealous flirt with other women in
front of her do not dissuade other women
from flirting with you
women will never admit this but jealousy
excites them
it does do you guys know why women get
jealous by the way
i was i was going to do a standalone
video on this women don't get jealous
of men and other women because of
love or because of they're afraid to get
a
std or because of him being intimate
with her
women get jealous for far different
reasons than men get jealous of
i've been going through david buses the
evolution of desire and he spends a
good uh portion of one chapter on this
women get jealous because they fear the
loss
of attention resources and safety
for the most part nothing else it's what
like it's why uh highly successful men
throughout history like let's call them
legends
um ishmael the bloodthirsty is one
example that comes to mind
uh rana harem of i think it was 800 plus
women
he sired over 900 children in fact by
the by the time his
wives got to the age of 30 he would
basically retire them out to pasture and
bring in
new younger wives throughout his entire
lifespan which is why which is how he
sired almost
a thousand kids um women don't get
jealous so long as they
get the dopamine hit from
the resources the protection and the
attention
that's why men have been able to run
harems but women
throughout history never have you've
never heard any
i've never heard it anyway any examples
of women running
harems of men they try to do it today i
mean sometimes you
see women try to do it today because
they think that um
you know because the toxic version of
feminist says that
women and men are equal and women should
behave as men do but
we know how badly that goes down it
fails terribly but
anyway back to point number two uh women
never admit this but jealousy excites
them it really does they want to know
that you're desirable by
other women the thought of you turning
on another woman will arouse her
sexually
i can tell you this i mean if you go to
a restaurant like he opens with flirt
with other women if you go to a
restaurant
and i'm not saying like you know flirt
with her in the sense that it's
blatantly obvious
and you're getting her phone number um
or anything like that
but women will send signals of
interest you may not notice it as
as much as women do i think they pick up
on it a lot sooner
and the signals at a higher frequency
that we do
but even if she smiles at you a certain
way or talks to you a little bit longer
than what she normally would with
another clientele
in front of your woman that's all that's
needed
okay and she actually likes that i mean
she's gonna find it annoying but at the
end of the day she's gonna she's gonna
go home with you she's gonna lie beside
you and she's gonna know that other
women desire you
women hate being with men that are
undesirable women hate being with men
that other women don't want to be with
it's just they actually despise it like
women literally despise
beta males that do not get looked at by
other women
right walk into a room and command the
attention of the room
she's gonna like that trust me um
so let's keep going no girl wants a man
that no other woman wants we've
talked about that the partner who
harnesses the gale storm of jealousy
controls the direction of
the relationship pretty straightforward
stuff no questions there number two make
her jealous
you